♪♪
-Let's get to the news.
President Biden travels to New
Jersey and New York today
to survey storm damage from the
remnants of Hurricane Ida.
Then he's gonna head to Texas
to look into that abortion law,
and maybe drop by Florida to get
some folks to wear a mask.
If there's time,
head to California,
help with that recall mess
and then finish up the week
in Maine to kill those
lobster zombies.
Oh, did you not hear?
Yeah, every state
has something bad.
According to a new poll,
President Biden's
approval rating has dropped six
points since June
but then it went back up
and then it fell again
and then it went back up.
Then it kinda fell again
then it kinda just stayed down
for a-- you know what,
I'm not being clear.
Do we have, like, any sort of
visual illustration?
It's so helpful.
According to a new report,
former First Lady Melania Trump
has only been seen publicly
once this summer.
Also, privately,
said her husband.
We had to put his picture up
so people remember.
A diner in Central Florida last
week began receiving
attention online after it said
it would not serve anyone
who voted for President Biden.
I don't know how to tell you
this, diner in Central Florida,
but you already weren't.
What happened,
you got suspicious
after somebody tipped?
Producers have announced they'll
delay the release of the movie
"Jackass Forever" due --
uh, sorry --
They're gonna delay it to next
year.
Gosh, Wally, and I had you put
everything in quotes
so I wouldn't stumble over it.
This is my jackass,
reading this card.
Producers announced they'll
delay the release of the movie
"Jackass Forever" to next year
due to a surge
in coronavirus cases.
Though, that would've made a
pretty good stunt.
I'm Johnny Knoxville
and this is
going to the movies
in a pandemic.
Billionaire Mark Cuban recently
became an investor
in a start-up company that is
creating artificial intelligence
versions of NFTs that have the
ability to converse with people,
raising the obvious question,
what?
Amazon's medical business,
Amazon Care,
is reportedly looking to start
offering in-person visits
in 20 major U.S. cities.
And they're focusing on the
places where people need
the most medical help,
their own warehouses.
And, finally,
kids are going back to school,
the NFL is about to kickoff
their season,
and the pumpkin spice latte
is back
you know what that means right?
That's right, it's summer.
It's still summer.
♪♪
White House Press Secretary
Jen Psaki said in a briefing
yesterday that there are about
100 American citizens
still in Afghanistan.
Though, Psaki stressed they're
doing everything in their power
to move on to the next question.
Pro-Trump protesters gathered in
New Jersey yesterday
and President Biden surveyed
storm damage from Hurricane Ida,
okay, but Trump is gone,
so what you guys are
is pro storm damage.
After the Taliban announced a
new all-male interim government
in Afghanistan yesterday,
the State Department
released a statement voicing
concern over the lack of women.
Um, you know that's kinda their
whole deal, right?
Its' like walking into a KKK
meeting and saying
"Wow, just white guys, okay."
Today was Senator Bernie Sanders
80th birthday.
Happy Birthday, Bernie,
I would've gotten you something
but then I would've had to
get it for everybody.
A 21-foot statue of Confederate
General Robert E. Lee
was taken down today in Virginia
but only because
they finally finished their
22-foot statue of him.
A video recently gained
attention on social media
showing Rudy Giuliani shaving
at a table
in an airport restaurant.
And it's even worse
than it sounds
because he was shaving his
bikini line.
That's right, a video showed
Rudy Giuliani shaving
at a restaurant table
in JFK Airport.
To be fair, he thought he was
at La Guardia.
We had some discussion,
we caught a little flak
based from some people here
who noted that happened
a long time ago.
Like, all --
that was last week.
But, come on, guys.
I know we're going back in time
a little bit
but you're gonna let that happen
on our hiatus
and we're just never
gonna talk about it?
No.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no.
The host of the children's show
"Blue's Clues" Steve Burns
released a video yesterday in
honor of his 25th anniversary.
But this is weird,
just to remind everyone that
Blue would be long dead by now.
Must be nice to be Ian,
sitting alone in your apartment.
"You go say it."
I just write it,
you say it.
And, finally, custom officials
in Texas recently fine a man
$500 after he allegedly tried to
smuggle more than 300 pounds
of bologna and ham
over the border.
It was a tough day for the
smuggler,
but a career day for the
drug-sniffing dogs.
♪♪
President Biden, today,
outlined the next phase
of his administration's
pandemic response.
And it's tough, but fair.
White House officials have asked
multiple members
of the military academy boards
who were appointed
by former President Trump
to resign
including former White House
press secretaries
Sean Spicer
and Kellyanne Conway.
Spicer is currently on the board
of the Naval Academy and Conway
is on the board of the
Academy of the French Calvary?
After Virginia removed the
21-foot statue
of Confederate General
Robert E. Lee,
from the State Capitol,
former President Trump
released a statement saying
the U.S. would've succeeded
in Afghanistan if Lee had been
in command.
Dude, he got his ass kicked
in Virginia.
What do you think the problem
was, too many trees?
Former New Jersey Governor
Chris Christie spoke
tonight at
the Ronald Reagan Library
about the future of the
Republican Party.
I guess it's always good to get
in an outside opinion.
The Taliban, yesterday,
announced a ban on all protests
and slogans that do not have the
interim government's approval.
Hence Pizza Hut's new slogan
in Afghanistan.
Donald Trump Jr. claimed in a
recent Instagram post that
former President Trump,
"Took more crap than any other
President, times about 1,000."
Wow, 1,000? That's even more
than fourscore and seven.
North Korean leader, Kim Jong-un
is receiving attention online
after appearing at a military
parade earlier today
looking noticeably slimmer.
This first reported in North
Korea's "Help Us: Weekly."
In honor of Disney World's 50th
anniversary,
McDonald's has announced it will
release 50 new Happy Meal toys
that feature Disney characters.
50!
You're really digging deep.
"I got Mickey, what'd you get?"
"Um, the dead lady from 'Up'?"
Netflix has announced that a new
season of
"The Great British Baking Show"
will premiere later this month.
"Oh, thank God!"
Said over scheduled therapists.
Authorities in Florida recently
arrested a woman who allegedly
drove a golf cart through an
active police standoff
while naked and intoxicated.
Which sounds insane,
but come on, it's Florida.
They only caught her because she
crashed into another naked woman
in a golf cart.
And finally, Mercedes Benz is
set to reveal new electric cars
next weekend at m-- the Munich
Auto Show as well as a car
that parks itself across two
handicapped spots.
And that, you guys,
was a monologue.
♪♪